why are you interested in cryptocurrency
is it just a financial investment or is
there a philosophy that attracts you to
a philosophy so i
my friend told me about in 2017 i was
actually i went to i was i was my friend
met me in shanghai i fought in one
championship um and he told me and the
second he told me i'm like
i'm so in because i read ron paul and
the fed i read i you know kind of
understanding how the fed is
unfair
um and so we told him about crypto this
decentralized system that no one has
control over
it just made sense and so like we've had
we have the podcast we would say michael
sailor on it and i love the way he said
it's like who do you trust more with
your money do you trust the politicians
or do you trust engineers
i think that's an easy choice i don't
even think i don't even think i have to
think about that i don't trust
politicians no matter what country they
come from china america wherever i don't
trust them
so what about uh into in uh
2017 what was bitcoin
are you um
what do you what do you find which ones
do you find interesting
yeah there's all kinds of ideas so
there's the the more
sort of primal mechanism of
proof-of-work and bitcoin and then
there's smart contracts ideas and
uh there's all kinds of innovations
across the different uh
so i can't say i'm in super deep where i
understand the technical components of a
lot of them i understand what bitcoin
can do for people and so that's probably
the one i focused the most on um and i
actually
i think i was talking about i was trying
to convince michael to talk about
bitcoin because he hates it also with
dinner last night and i think most of
the main problems bitcoin solves
people in america are so
american-centric they don't understand
it so like high levels of inflation that
hasn't happened it was starting to
happen it hasn't happened in america in
a long time right but someone in
venezuela is like oh i get that you know
or
remittance payments right remittance
payments to
you see it so i saw this in um when i
was spending all the time in singapore
singapore is obviously a really wealthy
country and so you'd have indonesian
workers or philippines and they would
all go on sundays they would go to these
places to ship stuff back to their
families and through western union
western union gouges the out of
these people i mean they're taking eight
ten twelve percent of whatever they're
sending then it takes five days and the
person's gonna pick it up whereas
bitcoin i could send you bitcoin person
to person right so like american people
don't understand that american people
don't really understand the unbanked
right a decent portion of the world is
unbanked they don't have access to it
and a much much much smaller portion of
the world doesn't have access to
internet so if i can put a mobile wallet
on your phone and we can send money
person to person so there's a whole
bunch of those problems where americans
don't really think about that are really
obvious that this solves
so i think that's the key one obviously
the fact that i'm
the value goes up is really outstanding
also but i but if you look at it
yeah i got in in 2017 so i got to watch
it go up i didn't sell at the top
really stupid and then the majority of
my time was spent through the bear
market and so i had to love it for the
principles that it provided not the fact
that actually i actually lost money in
the beginning and not now i'm way up but
um yeah so i'm just holding just holding
i think at the top of this bull market
i'll probably sell a very small portion
um just so you mean like right now
there's a bull market
yeah most most people think say in the
next 36 months will be the top of the
market and so probably when that happens
uh i'll probably sell a little bit
yeah you gotta huddle it ben you got a
hot well yeah and so i well i don't
here's what i i have so my pot one of my
podcast co-hosts he's he's like super
rich like uber rich so he has lost touch
with the every man yeah so here's my
argument to him it's really simple um
and listen i'm doing well for myself in
life but
if say someone buys a bitcoin right one
bitcoin five thousand dollars which it
was last year
and this bitcoin goes from five thousand
dollars to two hundred thousand dollars
which is you know right around what a
lot of people think the peak is going to
be they bought one bitcoin and they are
living in a 200 000 house so
to take
half of that right you started with 5
000 of the bitcoin to sell half a
bitcoin
for a hundred thousand dollars and pay
off your house your remaining house
payment that's life-changing to someone
it really is and so you still have a
bitcoin so if bitcoin goes to a million
you're still gonna have half a million
and you're gonna feel really really rich
with it half a million dollars because
you bought it for for every twenty five
hundred dollars you know yeah so yeah so
i would encourage anyone who's not uber
rich
to if you have huge profits take a
little bit of them because it could
change your life
and if you hold it and it goes down
you're going to feel the pain of that
like so sometimes if you're more
constrained financially
it's much more psychologically difficult
to ride the ups and downs yeah it is for
sure this they have this really
fascinating things in bitcoin actually i
said the guy on one of the main guys on
our podcast it's called on chain metrics
so all all wallet transactions are
visible you know and so they have these
all these fun categories i love so i
actually i think you don't like numbers
but i like numbers
i love numbers also so they have all
these different categories like um you
can see how long a wall that has held uh
a bitcoin right or how many bitcoins are
in a certain wallet and so what they've
seen during this the downturn right so
april it kind of peaked and went down is
that the the whales are still boston
whales people of a thousand or more are
still buying
they've said the main group of sellers
is the ones who held it from zero to
three months so like they don't have
money they bought it because they
thought it was going up and i was like
oh i gotta sell it right whereas
anyone's head out for a long time is
generally still holding on
you